breaking news right now on the
unprecedented trump fbi raid the
department of justice is asking to keep
the affidavit sealed now that's the
document that would give the underlying
reason on how the feds are able to
obtain the search warrant and that comes
as president trump levels new
accusations of fbi overreach quote they
stole my three passports one expired
along with everything else this is an
assault on a political opponent at a
level never seen before in our country
third world exclamation point
trump also claims he had a standing
order that allowed him to declassify
documents as soon as they left the oval
office and says the fbi took documents
protected under attorney-client
privilege now that comes as a growing
number of republicans are calling on the
justice department to release the
affidavit that attorney general merrick
garland used to sign off on the search
warrant former federal prosecutor andy
mccarthy says there's more to the raid
than what the feds have indicated
what i thought they were up to here
was basically trying to do a fishing
expedition to see if they could find
information that's relevant to the
capital riot that might help them
make a case arising out of january 6th
and looking at the warrant i think
that's exactly what it is
meanwhile the white house continues to
claim ignorance of the raid
we do not interfere we do not get
briefed
the department of justice again when it
comes to law enforcement matters it is
independent complete independence and
i'm just not going to comment on that
none of us will because we're going to
let merrick garland speak for himself we
have learned about all of this the same
way the american people have learned
about this
it's an interesting thing i i have
opined that i think that it would have
been reasonable and smart and
responsible for there at least to be
some sort of communication from justice
department to the white house they're
claiming that not how they're going to
do things as they say they don't didn't
know
and i just wonder you know if that will
if that is going to hold deagan going
forward
um it shouldn't hold every sober-minded
american who cares about this country
and the disunion that is uh gripping it
understands the justice department and
the federal well the fbi and even the
white house they need to show what
necessitated and justified this rating
and searching of the former president's
home it's never happened before period
and the reason needs to be extreme
because the measure is extreme
right now
right now it's the appearance that
garland and ray accompany that they
weaponize their agencies to go after the
adversaries of those in power namely
biden and all the people working for him
in a normal criminal case and i've
talked to andy mccarthy at length about
this law enforcement would arrest the
individual on the day that the search
warrant is executed and very often you
have the probable cause of a crime the
arrest warrant and the search warrant
use the same affidavit
but i don't think and i could be wrong
if the judge rules differently i don't
think that the affidavit and i don't
think any of the evidence that was
collected will ever see the light of day
until there's a january sixth indictment
i don't think it's going to ever be
related to this document search or the
republicans take retake the house and or
the senate but i i want to point out
that
this arrest
the i mean the no arrests the timing of
this raid was it happened after congress
was gone
for they were out on their august recess
so it was done intentionally at that
time i think to disperse that kind of
outrage across um out outside of the
beltway well i didn't really disperse it
all that well richard because uh there
is outrage but um even though these are
uh people these two people george f well
and susan collins she's a senator from
maine and he's of course columnist not
fans necessarily of president trump not
strong supporters but they both came out
and had a similar tone saying that there
needs to be more clarity from the a.g
about the unprecedented nature of this
and these documents and they're urging
the aeg to do more do you think you'll
hear from him this week i don't think
we're going to hear from the ag i think
when he spoke last week that was it but
i actually agree with with george will i
agree with senator susan collins because
of this level of outrage let's go ahead
and release the affidavit and when we
release the affidavit i think we need to
be very clear that each and every day in
this country um probable cause of
warrants are issued they're served and
they're processed i mean while it was a
different court everybody remembers the
story of brianna taylor who died because
of a probable cause warrant and a no
knock probable cause warrant that caused
her to lose her life when there was no
there was nothing there was actually a
fraudulent warrant we now find out
because the federal charges have been
filed against the officers in that case
so when we think about probable cause
warrants if we're going to be outraged
let's have a conversation about changing
the system instead of just being
outraged when it happens to the former
president of the united states when he's
holding on to classified documents i
guess it's possible i could lead to that
well before i ask you your question if
you kill that fly
that's coming around here i'm gonna give
you a hundred dollars i saw it i thought
why didn't you make that offer to me
richard
it's because he's taller you think he
has better reach i don't know i'm like
i'm thinking about his reflexes
if i
swatted that fly that was messing with
richard it would come off like i was
swatting it richard and he would not go
i promise you um so we are eight days
since
the well i guess a week tonight is when
the the search warrant was we found out
about the search warrant um i don't know
if we actually know all that much more
because honestly it is a little bit hard
to keep up with it was these documents
then they're not they're nuclear but
they're not but they're this and then
they're not and it's i think greg and
i'm talking in the green room like some
it's kind of hard to
figure it out and then it's like well we
got us just basically
i don't know i'm not losing interest in
it at all i'm just kind of frustrated
about not having any information but i
think it will stay in an intentionally
ambiguous place a a blank slate that
serves the fbi and the doj's purpose of
finding anything i agree with andy
mccarthy it is a fishing expedition
we'll never see the probable cause
affidavit that you reference i think
you're right about that dagon that would
require specificity and if that's the
case then they would be boxed into us
understanding what it is they went in
looking for it's not truly about
declassified materials or classified
materials it's not even really about the
espionage act which by the way can
encompass and does in the statute very
minor grievances like not giving
information over to the national
archives not that you're a super spy
with the nuclear codes but you just
didn't simply comply with the national
archives it's not about any of that it
is a blank slate that allows the doj to
find something anything to disqualify
donald trump from running from president
either disqualify him in a long
drawn-out legal case that ends up at the
supreme court or simply in the american
public's mind and if that's the case to
your point dagon it better be egregious
it better be
more than the nuclear codes which let's
be real change when an administration
changes
very cryptic egregious they change
regularly right i was kidding the day
that i said that about nuclear codes
that's not like you don't write them on
a scrap of paper i do but greg does
your nuclear codes are having to deal
with something else yes that is the
truth do you want to hear from bill
maher sure let's see what he had to say
trump he did sell his soul to the devil
because he is the luckiest man in the
world
his fortune was finally falling desantis
was beating him in the polls you know
who hates this more than anybody
descendants
i had this in the bag and now i gotta
run against president martyr
and and this is saving trump politically
because now of course all the
republicans
what do they do of course talking there
to our friend piers morgan there you go
our very own piers morgan uh there's
something there there's truth to what
he's saying no matter how you feel about
trump and and bill maher can't stand him
he's a larger in life figure and you
just create more folk hero status the
more you target him he understands that
he's like a black hole that swallows all
negative energy and then and the angrier
you get the better it works the how
stupid was this he it's like found money
for him right this raid has found money
he doesn't have to do anything he could
just pull back and just let this play
out he already looks like he
he was the victim here meanwhile of
course they're going to work around the
clock trying to find stuff about it but
it's already felt falling apart i think
and i think we were seeing it fall apart
towards friday the tell
for me was if you criticized the
political nature uh of this raid it was
tantamount to hate speech and they do
this before they did this to like if
parents said hey look i don't want to
have um
gender experts talking about gender
politics with my toddler and said well
you know what you're putting trans
people in harm's way or if you say
something you're at a school board
meeting you say look i don't want um i
don't think crt should be in uh
in schools and i don't think this
shutdown is working in schools well you
know you're a domestic terrorist by
saying that so the what they try to do
is they try to shut you down by
saying you why what you how you feel the
anger you have is somewhat harmful that
was the tell that this was over of
course they never did they never cared
about the border patrol that's the best
you know when they talk about defending
law enforcement they actually put a
target on border patrol and then when
they were found innocent they still
decide to punish him so all of that
hypocrisy means nothing you should be
okay criticizing the fbi including fbi
agents who are criticizing him
the the final i think the final tell
though
is that now they're just saying you know
what maybe we'll never know right and
what they're trying that's the that's
the kind of the tell that they use with
hunter biden you know maybe this thing's
real after all you know but we already
won the election it really doesn't
matter so they wait until it doesn't
matter anymore and then they come up
with okay let's not talk about it it's
what people do when they're married it's
like okay let's just not talk about it
you win
yeah that's usually how i always win yes
no kidding i don't know maybe i actually
i do i went on brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now